you know i was thinking about you and
your wife i don't know that you ever
wanted kids or not but
i'm glad you you don't i i'm glad you
don't have kids because you are into so
many things and so many projects i don't
think
you would be able to give the time to
being a good father and
oh no for sure not um or or i wouldn't
be able to do all this work that i like
um no i it's 100 people are always like
and it's something i think i was
uncomfortable
answering this before but they were like
how do you do so much and like the
answer is
i don't have kids like if people like
how do you do pottery and write a book
and make all these movies and tv shows
it's
it's that i don't have kids well because
all of this nothing else to do
all of this stuff requires a tremendous
amount of time
and self-involvement and you're right
not that
why put a kid through that if you don't
have time for a kid and lauren's down
with this too right she's okay she
doesn't want
you know i would say she wants kids less
than i do like
and if she is going to be talked into it
she is like no
would that have been a deal breaker in
your romantic relationship if if she had
really wanted a bunch of kids would it
have been
no that's the thing i think i could wrap
my head around it
but i think she's just like uh no
[Music]
[Laughter]
right which is great we have so much fun
like i don't know anyone who gets as
much happiness out of their kids as we
get out of our non-kids
like we're [ __ ] psyched all the time
we're laying in bed on saturday morning
smoking weed like watching movies naked
just being like if we had kids we could
not be [ __ ] doing things like this
like there is no one whose child is
giving them as much joy
as we are right now getting because we
do not have a kid it's not an easy haul
having kids you cannot be a you can't be
narcissistic
you have to give yourself over to
parenting and uh they've got to be the
priority
yeah i don't want that yeah yeah
[Music]
that's that's that does not sound fun to
me
and why there's enough kids out there oh
there's so many
more we need more people who looks at
the planet right now
and things you know we need more [ __ ]
people like that's what
that is truly a confounding thing to me